we've all been there before sitting in a
packed theater staring up at the silver
screen scratching our heads wondering
where we've seen a certain actor before
in the case of the actress who stars in
the 2019 horror sequel 47 metres down
uncaged she won't catch your eye for any
of her previous work on film or
television rather it's down to her
family name and how it's placed her in
the public eye from a very young age and
put her on a path towards stardom
leading 47 metres down uncaged the
sequel to 2017 s 47 metres down is
cysteine rose stallone who has a very
famous father in Rocky and Rambo
franchise star Sylvester Stallone the
striking 21 year old makes her feature
film debut in uncaged playing a teenage
girl named Nicole who dives into a
ruined underwater city with three of her
closest friends much to their horror the
four girls soon discover that the secret
city is home to threats of all kinds
including the deadliest sharks known to
man the younger Stallone has been in the
Hollywood spotlight for a long time
thanks to her easily recognizable father
throughout her life she's appeared
alongside her dear old dad at movie
premieres glitzy Hollywood outings and
film festivals like Ken so if you feel
like you've seen her dirty blond hair
and brown eyes somewhere before it's
likely that you saw a snap of sistine
and Sylvester together on the red carpet
you may have also seen her up on the
Golden Globe Awards stage in 2017 as
Miss Golden Globe an honor given to
up-and-coming children of prominent
Hollywood celebrities while Stallone hit
the genetic jackpot and being the
daughter of a Hollywood legend and
former model Jennifer flavin she isn't
solely relying on her famous family to
carve out a career for herself
of course her conventional good looks
and surname that's instantly linkable to
her father have helped set her up for
fame as evidenced by her 1 million plus
followers on Instagram but Stallone
worked hard to establish herself as a
model prior to jumping in the acting
world only wear a red lip but I love
what they did
she signed with IMG Models in 2016 and
has walked in Dolce & Gabbana and Chanel
fashion shows she's also been on the
cover of Town & Country and Elle Russia
ironically enough while Stallone has
said she's always dreamt of modeling and
even loves it so much that she would
work for free she once said that she
could never picture herself getting into
acting she told The Hollywood Reporter
in January 2017 as for me I don't think
I could ever act I'm good for modelling
because I don't have to talk acting is
something you're born with with a mother
like Jennifer flavin sistine Rose was
bound to try her hand at modelling and
with a father like sylvester stallone
how could she not be born with the
acting gene firmly in place
she's got the best of both worlds let's
just hope that her acting chops are as
impressive as her father's catch sistine
roast alone in 47 metres down uncaged
when the horror film swims into theaters
on August 16th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]